démarrer quand même
j'ai fait un relevé à l'époque tu parles
de moi
il y a que moi qui entends romain la
belle voix de ténor de Romain toute
coupée
ah non là on n'est pas encore parti
j'attends de
j'attends que ça soit lancé sur nos
chaînes respectives
pas de mal
ah voilà
on va pouvoir y aller
c'est bon il y a des gens qui arrivent
dans le chat allez on y va salut tout le
monde bienvenue pour la reformation des
Beatles quelques années après puisque
alors moi j'ai même pas fait le live de
la drogue je me suis rendu compte en
écoutant mais il y avait il y avait
baigne emmanu il y avait romain Alan
nous avait rejoint après
à l'équipe envergure mais on avait fait
4h30 de la F de draft et c'était quand
même une draft très très marquante
voir la plus marquante des années 2010
il s'est passé des trucs assez fou quand
même pendant cette draft donc on va
pouvoir en parler salut tout le monde
dans le chat
beaucoup de beaucoup de monde Lionel
Marius et guazy Toto salut les gars ou
les filles et
donc nous avons el Manu elle Manu Manu
Manu Manu comment vas-tu
[Musique]
romain deuxième fois de la semaine qu'on
se voit romain ça n'arrête pas ça
nous avons el baignoire ça fait
longtemps aussi ça va mon ben oui ça va
regarder les matchs mais j'ai pas eu le
temps vraiment de m'appliquer à faire
des
affaires des scalping tout ça j'avais
hâte de venir discuté avec vous c'est
les choses de la vie et Alan Guillou
Grad assistante Santa Clara est avec
nous
West Coast et défaite hier soir pour toi
donc tu vas t'ouvrir quand même
la défaite c'est un gros match quand
même donc ça va face à Gonzaga
effectivement bon je vous ai demandé
préparer que des petits trucs un peu
rigolos et ben je commence avec toi
direct oui parce que là on va commencer
évidemment ce qui est le plus rigolo
quand même c'est de voir là où on s'est
trompé la draft 2018 je vous on pour
ceux qui étaient pas né en 2018 et qui
nous regarde on rappelle quand même dit
andréaton
Marvin baglet oui Marvin baglet
ensuite Lucas duncitch trade
Jackson junior triang et ensuite des
gens accessoires chez Alexander un peu
plus bas les bridges dans entre 10 et 20
il y avait du monde
ta meilleure erreur ben sur cette draft
2018 ma meilleure erreur c'est une de
mes plus grosses erreurs que j'ai jamais
fait en scalping juste Alexander je sais
pas si vous rappelez mais moi les
premiers matchs que j'ai vu je le voyais
pas du tout le je voyais un grand
asticots secs qui allait toujours en
ligne droite qui était pas physiquement
très robuste qui se faisait bloquer le
chemin qui était pas le plus rapide non
plus je me console en me disant qu'on
n'était pas la seule personne à avoir
fait cette erreur là parce que parce
qu'il y a pas montré l'ombre de ce qui a
montré en NBA à Kentucky 11 le rang
numéro 11 me
paraissait un peu haut pour lui mais si
on avait à refaire la draft demain matin
je le drive très probablement deux ou
troisièmes
et ouais et pourquoi tu penses que on
s'est trompé alors qu'est-ce qui se
passe c'est quelque chose que j'ai
appris à cette draft-là et que je je
martèle à tout le monde c'est le
contexte contexte contexte contexte
contexte
il est arrivé à NBA
juste Alexander avec les Clippers mais
il était échangé dans le trade de Paul
George à au clairement City où il avait
absolument
cartable blanche à savoir qu'est-ce qui
allait qu'est-ce qui voulait faire
qu'est-ce qu'il allait faire comment y
aller
comment il allait gérer l'attaque et ce
sont des rendus compte c'est que je suis
avec sa mère savait vraiment très bien
jouer au basket et jouer elle savait
jouer au basket d'une manière qui est
intériorisée c'est-à-dire ici où se
placer ici
ils connaissent son personnel il sait
comment le donner le ballon personnel
capable de se correr capable de dribbler
capable de passer son gars aussi il y
avait cette fameuse et cette fameuse
qualité là qu'on lui connaissait pas qui
est la décélération qui est vraiment un
peu comme le la qualité du moment donc
je pense que c'est peut-être l'exemple
le plus probant de de la toilette
bouchée au Kentucky qui l'empêchait de
s'exprimer
donc
il fait quand même hein on est traîné
oui et il y avait impressionné au
Clippers est-ce que je me rappelle mais
ils étaient pas dans les dépôt
titulaires il est arrivé à aucun mosti
on a carrément redéfini qu'est-ce qu'on
devait attendre de chaque et juste
Alexander et à mon avis on a pas fini de
redéfinir qu'est-ce qu'on attend de
faire Alexander je pense qu'il a pas
encore tapé tout ce qu'il y avait de son
potentiel c'est proche il s'en vient
mais je pense qu'on a pas encore tout vu
de lui moi c'est je suis devenu un gars
qui croyait pas un gars qui croit béton
les autres vous l'aviez aussi j'ai
réécouté du coup notre poste notre
podcast post draft pas facile à dire
non c'est pas ça
prononcer non
c'est
un raté et c'est un raté pour moi
à l'époque aussi c'est à dire que je
l'avais même pas mis au programme du
podcast du bon voilà et de rester en 11
ce n'est pas important
donc effectivement on a appris
Manu toi tu le tu l'avais plus haut que
ça tu t'étais un peu comme ben tu te
disais bon ça va pas terrible
de mémoire j'étais un peu 55 ans sur lui
j'essaie pas trop quoi m'attendre avec
son on avait vu à qui ou il y avait pas
forcément la balle en main il était plus
dans le corner un peu à la à la Jamal et
qui fait que tirer il avait ce rôle là
et du coup je disais bah c'est un peu
bizarre c'est pas trop à quoi s'attendre
au niveau supérieur et arriver au
Clippers et maintenant au Thunder
on lui a donné les clés du camion ils se
rend compte qu'en fait d'aller juste
monstrueux
et qu'il est capable de tout faire
quasiment maintenant
Allan
suivi cette draft suite avait été
à vraiment comprendre
quoi faire avec les les gardes de Cali
Paris en fait je n'arrivais pas
tellement encore à matérialiser
qu'est-ce qui commence à se projeter une
bière il y avait on sortait de booker
Murray et Fox trois ans de suite
et en fait ce que je me rappelle par
contre c'est que j'ai il avait son rôle
il avait changé
dans l'année au début c'est pas une
recrue c'est pas une des recrues les
plus les plus importantes c'était
l'équipe de Kevin Knox puis Jay
Washington et quoi des Green à la main
et en fait au
début des matchs de conférence et les
stades que le montre les stades changent
en fait calibar il lui donne la balle et
il a beaucoup plus d'importance de Ball
en main sur les sur les matchs de
conférence donc il y avait eu deux
saisons de chez dans sa dans sa saison à
Kentucky mais on avait pas encore trop
matérialisé ce que ça voulait dire et je
m'attendais surtout pas
ce développement handball je pensais que
ça allait être un solide roalplayer long
qui pouvait défendre plusieurs positions
mais je m'attendais pas
un candidat all NBA dans sa quatrième
année quoi c'est ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui
absolument et
chez le guide du je pense que on
personne l'avait dans son top 10 à
l'époque et donc ce qu'on peut retenir
dans ce que tu résumes Alan c'est quand
même que il faut faire attention aux
évolutions à l'intérieur d'une seule et
même saison sur surtout pour des des
gamins quoi qui sont fraîchement
ce qui est intéressant aussi dans ce cas
là c'est que le hype prêterave c'était
vraiment très réel il est passé de on le
repêche pas la loterie à ils auraient
plus partir en 6 ou - 8 il est Cleveland
lui a donné un coup d'œil avant de rater
Coline Sexton donc il y avait vraiment
il y avait vraiment quelque chose à
propos du profil physique de chaque vous
avez tous échappé pendant l'analyse du
romain ta plus belle erreur draft 2018 à
ton avis
j'ai des coudes ça te soumettre non mais
vas-y
c'est
j'avais pas
lu de temps
mais je pense si autre chose
je
regardais là instant
perdu pardon vraiment mais moi je
t'entends haché
je te reprends après comme ça tu as le
temps de regarder les productions stats
on va essayer de régler ce problème
évidemment c'est pas un live envergure
s'il y a pas de problème les amis c'est
pas pas de problème pas de souci
ouais ouais mais désolé le chat pour
pour cette petite cette petite
interruption sonore Manu je te pose la
même question du coup plus gros erreur
je sais pas si ça va répondre à tes
questions moi c'était mon Bamba que je
voyais comme le deuxième meilleur
prospect draft à l'époque derrière donc
si tu
et finalement le contexte Orlando ne l'a
pas aidé les blessures non plus le covid
non plus et là aujourd'hui quatre ans
après 4-5 ans après il a complètement
disparu même si ça débute saison plutôt
correct
mais il est
il a pas répondu à mes attentes en tout
cas je croyais beaucoup notamment au tir
extérieur qui est jamais trop venu
même deux et du coup ça l'a bien freiné
sur ces années de pâle sur sa
progression là ça commence un petit peu
je trouve cette année mais il après
c'est un grand peut-être que dans deux
ans on se dira waouh en fait il était
trop fort
les grands mettent plus longtemps à
atteindre leur pique souvent en tout cas
donc c'est vrai que il a quel âge mon
Bamba là il doit avoir 23 comme ça
donc effectivement mais alors qui t'a
dit on va faire ça après j'ai un
j'ai des citations de notre podcast post
draft mais qui a dit
dans absolument la pire situation il va
avoir des difficultés à s'accomplir
absolument c'est Benoît Lelièvre qui
n'avait pas complètement tort j'avais
100% raison
effectivement mon Bamba toi tu l'avais
où Allan tu te rappelles ou pas
compliqué
[Musique]
de mes deux grosses erreurs et projets
physiques du mot bon base à hirs Smith
ah ouais parle-nous de Zair Smith
attends ça c'est génial moi aussi je
l'avais top j'avais loterie
ouais je crois c'est ma plus grosse
erreur peut-être all time je vais
l'avoir top 5 je pense parce que je
voyais vraiment en fait j'ai acheté le
tir mais j'ai pas compris que le volume
était aussi super important dans
l'analyse d'un prospect surtout qu'a
fait qu'une seule année parce que si tu
regardes les stats oui shoot à 45% à 3
points sur ce sera la seule année à
texas tech mais c'est sur que 40 tirs en
fait garantir en une trentaine de matchs
et 95% de ces tirs et c'était du
quartier de jute donc aujourd'hui avec
le recul jamais je mettrai jamais
j'achèterai autant le tir d'un joueur
qui était de 1 à 71% lancé francs et de
deux prenez peu de tir et prenez surtout
du catching shoot dans les corners et
moi je m'étais dit j'aime je comprenais
pas encore je pensais que ça allait
pouvoir être devenir un vrai bon joueur
de de pull-up surtout qu'il était aussi
très à l'aise à mi distance il était à
44% ce qui est bien ce qui est vraiment
bien pour un joueur
qui était vif il était super athlétier
qui défendait de allez 1 à 4 je pense à
texastek 1 2 3 4
par exemple je préférais beaucoup plus
d'ailleurs Smith que en 2018 que
j'arrête que lever en 2019 pour moi il y
avait aucun aucun je préférais vraiment
d'ailleurs
Smith bah en fait il est connu aussi
parce qu'il est échangé le soir de la
draft côté
par Philadelphie mes Philadelphie
échanges Michael budges a Phoenix et en
fait Phoenix récupère ma Mika brilise et
on voit d'ailleurs Smith plus un autre
pic de mémoire et en fait
ça jamais marché d'ailleurs c'est que
c'est qu'il est déjà plus dans la ligue
et qu'il y a deux ans il était déjà plus
dans la ligue en fait donc
et puis c'est ça son rôle a pas été
vraiment défini on n'a pas vraiment
réussi à le et puis en fait le manque de
tir fait que tu pouvais parler dans une
équipe comme les stickers qui jouent
quelque chose donc
énormément ce qui m'avait arrêté à
l'époque chose à yasmisme je l'avais je
pense fin
à dos début 20e c'est qu'il a commencé à
jouer au basket à 16 ans il a commencé à
jouer au basket à 16 ans c'était un
receveur éloigné au foot et
oui le Prophète athlétique est
incroyable oui il était
au-dessus de la mêlée à texas tech mais
lorsque
ça s'éloigne lorsque ça lorsque le
niveau athlétique ce
segalise c'est sûr qu'il allait lui
manquer des outils dans la compréhension
du jeu comparé aux autres joueurs qui
avait bb qui avait qui avait joué toute
leur ville
c'est 13 matchs sur NBA exactement donc
je pense que c'était qui c'est break
Brown à l'époque
ça ça fonctionne pas du tout
[Musique]
avec le trade up pour aller chercher
Michael bridges à l'époque on pensait
que c'était pas top comme
je me rappelle en tout cas le lendemain
de la draft on était pas forcément très
convaincu même si on aime on a toujours
beaucoup aimé Michael bridges mais
les l'histoire a montré finalement que
les trade up dans cette zone de la draft
fonctionnait assez souvent de on peut
parler de novan Mitchell aussi l'année
d'avant
romain est-ce que tu me reçois
maintenant la question c'est ça si vous
m'entendez ou pas surtout ça c'est bon
c'est mes écouteurs
donc j'étais sur kill inox tout à
l'heure dans le sens où j'ai essayé
d'acheter parce que le profil physique
me plaisait donc par la longueur etc etc
donc j'ai essayé d'acheter et je prends
la fameuse règle des trois ans dans la
dans la phase dans le sens où tu es une
chute libre en fait donc bon
voilà passer de passer du choix qui
était le sien donc il doit être piqué
neuf au marasme au marasme de la
reconstruction des trois ou je pense que
d'ici peu et leur servir de monnaie
d'échange dans un trade pour un
improbable deuxième tour quelque part ça
va se terminer comme ça bon voilà j'ai
payé pour voir j'ai vu et voilà
effectivement alors tu étais pas non
plus à fond je m'en rappelle le soir de
la draft et pas non plus à fond dedans
mais tu te dis pourquoi pas tu te dis
pour toi je me dis pourquoi je suis pas
à fond parce que je pense qu'il y a il y
a encore un petit peu de matériel
intéressant de sous qui est pas parti
donc ça me surprend un peu de le voir le
voir là
un petit peu haut par rapport à aux
échanges qu'on avait pu avoir pendant la
saison notamment par rapport à lui mais
bon c'est d'y croire et en fait non
et alors savez-vous ce qui a dit Benoît
le soir de la draft
[Musique]
je trouve que les Nyx ont fait une draft
risquée mais intéressante ils vont
donner le développement et l'amour
nécessaire à Kevin Knox pour qu'il
devienne un bon joueur
car dans un nom donné trop à la première
billet il jouait 38 minutes par mois ça
c'est pour avoir Zion
[Musique]
début de l'époque de cette espèce de
filou de David filsderle qui se vantait
d'être un expert en développement des
joueurs qui a fait absolument planter
tout le monde mais
si vous vous rappelez les gars quelque
part au mois de mars de cette année-là
je vous ai demandé qu'est-ce qu'il a
comme skill kevenox niveau NBA je le
voyais pas à l'époque vous me l'avez
tous vendu je l'ai acheté
100 % ah c'est beau tu es en train de
dire que c'est de notre faute
sur le plan sur le plan des chiffres la
saison ok il a 28 minutes 13 points un
petit 35% à 3 points pour la saison
Wookie quatre bons et demi c'est pas
c'est par contre bon là c'est pas
parfait mais c'est pas c'est pas nul non
plus je suis plutôt plutôt cohérent par
rapport à un 9e choix
et puis
il y a l'impact sur le terrain et sur le
fait de gagner ou non et assez vite très
mauvais quand même même si c'est
rarement très bon pour les premières
années mais assez vite très mauvais pour
les pour l'argument beaucoup pendant ces
trois années à New York les gros
problèmes de kevenox c'était au niveau
physique il est très très longues jambes
et un centre de gravité très haut il y a
eu jamais été capable de mettre le
muscle nécessaire sur ses jambes pour
avoir de la stabilité alors il se
faisait défoncer aussi quand il prenait
à mi distance soit trois points
bon on a fait le tour bon moi j'avais
chez aussi donc j'ai pas
mais je dirais que l'erreur dont on
parle pas assez on avait tous Luca 1
mais je crois en tout cas quand j'écoute
le podcast de l'époque personne ne dit
Lucas ça va être une super star tu vois
il y a quasiment personne qui dit ça on
dit ouais ça va être peut-être un
All-Star peut-être un porteur primaire
etc mais alors que bon bah voilà
aujourd'hui force de constater que il en
a pour 10 ans de Don chic qui roule sur
toute compétition dans laquelle il est
engagé quoi donc
ça allait être un joueur qui allait
faire du 60-70 et extirpé une défaite
par lui-même de son équipe je pense pas
qu'on fasse douter de ce niveau là aussi
de la courbe que la NBA allait prendre
avec les initiateurs format géants
ouais mais c'était déjà un peu le cas
pardon mais LeBron était déjà
initiateur il y avait genre
beaucoup plus important
bon pour vous j'ai posé la question
bon ça va être lié mais pour vous qui a
fait qui a fait la meilleure draft de
cette cuvée 2018
les internautes sont unanimes pour
l'instant
enfin pas une année mais presque en tout
cas
donc à vous de me dire si vous êtes
d'accord avec le choix du peuple qui est
les Dallas Mavericks
[Musique]
après
pardon
cette zone de
contredire ça
mon souvenir avait fait une excellent
bref aussi
proposé même fils aussi avec Jared
Jackson junior et Jay von Carter à
l'époque c'est pas
ah non il le récupérera après ouais il
va même il a Phoenix Atlanta
mais alors du coup le la vraie question
c'est ça en fait la vraie question 9 ans
après c'est celle là c'est la question
de la polémique
est-ce que je veux dire Atlanta le choix
numéro 3 ils peuvent prendre le cadeau
de chic je décide de pas prendre le
cadeau de chic pour prendre le joueur
qui veulent il le voulait depuis
longtemps
et donc ils ont le choix 10 de l'année
d'après qui devient cam rédige qui
devient rien du tout au final puisque
ils ont ils ont réussi un second tour
avec un Reich
un choix de premier tour l'année
dernière ou l'année d'avant
draft et qui avec ça au Congo
Johnson non
Johnson on peut pas encore trop savoir
mais romain qu'est-ce que tu en dis
est-ce que est-ce que c'est en fait
parce que on est à peu près tous
d'accord pour dire que bah oui Phoenix
ils auraient dû prendre mon cadeau chic
Sacramento on vous a bien épargné
jusqu'ici mais votre tour viendra
mais évidemment qui doivent le prendre
maintenant est-ce que Atlanta a eu
raison de croire en son étoile triangle
qui est pas du tout un mauvais joueur
c'est pas ça la question
tous les points du process de
construction si tu reprends l'histoire
est-ce qu'à l'époque le trade entre
Golden State et Orlando pour Chris Weber
c'est quelque chose de judicieux tu
pourrais écrire les traînes comme ça
très haut est-ce que donc si tu aurais
eu le même
le même développement Atlanta tu peux tu
peux poser la question dans tous les
sens je pense que le fit à Dallas pour
moi était bon
Guillaume correspondait peut-être plus
aussi à ce qui se passait à Atlanta sur
la construction à l'époque et sur les
besoins de l'équipe voilà après derrière
on n'a pas tu utilises on n'a pas réussi
à projeter nous
[Musique]
les dans le sondage qu'on a mis sur sur
Twitter deuxième qui finira deuxième
meilleur joueur de cette cuvée derrière
Luca triangle arrive quand même derrière
chez guilde juice avec Sander qui est
plébiscité mais après on a beaucoup de
fans de question
[Musique]
moins que d'Atlanta
il y a un an les gens n'auraient pas dit
ça il y a même six mois je pense
après il y a des il y a des il y a des
problèmes enfin
je veux dire est-ce que est-ce que c'est
jouable de traîner triangle sur quatre
séries de playoffs sans empathie
énormément défensivement c'est une vraie
question je me rappelle qu'on avait
parlé c'est une vraie question si tu
construis autour de cet homme là puisque
c'était le but d'Atlanta
c'était les deux les deux joueurs en
haut de mon bord mais j'avais Luka tout
seul en haut donc pour moi il y a pas de
débat tu dois
même si tu as des étapes de
reconstruction différentes tu prends le
cas et tu pourras après je pense qu'il y
avait beaucoup de marketing aussi de ce
qui est ressorti sur Atlanta triangle
représenter peut-être beaucoup plus que
vous voulez le GM l'image de la ville et
j'avais pas mal d'articles sur ça comme
quoi
entre guillemets Lucas dans peut-être
pas fit la culture Atlanta
mais entre guillemets moi je m'en fiche
un peu je prends le meilleur joueur et
je ramènerai des gens dans ma salle
parce que j'ai un top 5 NBA futuro Famer
et un des meilleurs joueurs je pense à
son âge donc à 22 23 ans à des meilleurs
joueurs qu'on a vu dans l'histoire de la
NBA à son âge c'est-à-dire qu'un
attaquant de 22 ans 23 ans ce qui fait
depuis deux trois ans c'est irréel en
fait
il y a des limitations vraies comme je
dis vraies limitations physiques et de
triangles on l'a vu contre Miami l'an
dernier ou assez limitations défensive
elles sont importantes et son refus que
je regrette de vouloir jouer un peu
horse-ball c'est là où pour moi la
comparaison avec la jamais été bonne
parce que Steph curry t'apporte et le
meilleur shooter de tous les temps mais
aussi parce que il bouge beaucoup son
ballon et il peut être un vrai joueur de
catch and shoot là où triangle et plus
en initiateur offensif héliocentrique
super passeur mais qui joue jamais au
rôle donc en fait
et en fait il
profite même pas de son shoot qui est
super bon pour faire poser les défenses
sur le spacing et tout et pour créer un
peu du de la confusion of bol donc c'est
encore une des étapes dans son jeu qui
doit améliorer
la question d'un certain Hugues je sais
pas qui c'est Hugues
qu'est-ce que vous pensez des rumeurs
qui disaient Luca veut absolument aller
à Dallas est-ce que c'est possible de
choisir sa destination
de ce que vous savez non pas la vérité
mais romain est-ce que tu peux répondre
à ça ou pas
je sais pas si on peut choisir la
destination on sait qu'on peut mettre
des écrans de fumée sur certaines choses
pour limiter certains choix après
derrière
vraisemblablement je pense que si
l'entourage de don de chez FSH voilà
c'est je pense que c'est le côté un
petit peu
l'héritage Ludovici et le contexte sur
place qui lui était sûrement très
favorable pour plein de raisons
[Musique]
j'étais pas envie d'aller s'accramento
non plus c'est peut-être aussi une des
raisons pour laquelle ça cramer toi pas
rareté enfin c'est le problème c'est
qu'on encore une fois on n'est pas dans
les bureaux donc
est-ce qu'il y a un choix qui peut être
fait oui est-ce que est-ce qu'il y a eu
de la pression après en coulis sur tel
ou tel franchise pour dire si c'est moi
qui suis l'acheter derrière faudra
traîner toute façon c'est rien après
après
le choix Dallas pour moi me paraît quand
même très cohérent par rapport aux
autres ah oui non mais ça il y a pas de
l'histoire ça me paraît très cohérent de
surtout en pleine reconstruction et puis
reprendre le flambeau d'un joueur
européen la culture européenne elle est
pas forcément implantée dans toutes les
franchises de la même façon à Dallas on
sait qu'elle est donc pour moi c'est
c'est si l'histoire est vrai si c'est
cette histoire est vrai c'est en tout
cas un choix un choix cohérent et une
projection qui est tous au bête par
rapport par rapport au contexte
Manu
qu'est-ce que tu peux me dire sur la
draft de Phoenix parce que Phoenix à
l'époque tout le monde dit oh c'est pas
mal les drop diendraiton ils avaient
besoin d'un grand etc et effectivement
je viendrait ethon est un bon joueur de
NBA comment tu mets ça en perspective
aujourd'hui 4 ans après
ou il y a au moins trois joueurs
derrière lui allez au moins 3 qui sont
devenus des des premières options dans
des bonnes équipes de playoffs
ok si
moi je suis déçu sans être déçu
je m'attendais pas à ce qu'ils
deviennent beaucoup j'étais pas super
j'étais un petit je suis trop
intéressante j'étais pas ultra chaud sur
lui j'avais pas mal de questions et
finalement
il a un peu
surperformé par rapport à mes attentes
après le pour moi leurs meilleurs
joueurs c'est cassé presque une
callebridge sur Sunrise
un joueur qui est capable de défendre
sur le meilleur joueur adverse en
playoff
capable de sanctionner à trois points
quand maintenant il est ouvert ou voilà
ça peut devenir une arme en fait c'est
devenu une arme chez lui comme ce qui
n'est pas trop à Villa
et je pense que ouais c'est même c'est
le meilleur des deux joueurs finalement
aujourd'hui c'est lui qui attend après
ça reste une bonne draft quand même avec
le recul surtout si on considère le
trade en plus
ils sont pas ridicule c'est
une partie des cinq équipes à avoir fait
le meilleur choix
c'est vrai Alan là-dessus tu penses que
Phoenix pas tant de regrets que ça
si pour moi aussi
je suis désolé si
oui je suis d'accord sur ton site mais
eux ils avaient leur
leurs idées là-dessus enfin
compris le gars qui était d'Arizona il
pensait que
c'est pas prêt de leurs attentes elles
Phoenix
[Musique]
Paul ils ont eu bridge ils vont final
NBA ils sont à deux modes de gagner les
finales NBA et l'an dernier c'est la
meilleure équipe de saison régulière
donc en réalité c'est dur de leur dire
vous avez fait le mauvais choix ils sont
vraiment une super ossature et une super
équipe
mais on pourrait avoir devine booker à
l'occasion
et je pense que Lucas se développe
pareil et peut-être moins fort à tête
des statistiques moins ronflantes si il
joue à côté d'un devine booker même si
tu me diras il joue à côté de Jane
Branson l'an dernier Bronson faisait
d'énormes cartons aussi et ça marchait
très bien de bac courte avec les deux
mais
je sais pas comment on dit il y a les
franchises font leur font leurs études
avant de tout mais l'idée d'un fan or
qui connaît pas tout ça et qui imagine
juste peut-être l'association booker
donc si tu peux dire que c'est
c'est dommage
si t'as pas un grand soit elle te sert à
rien dans les faits parce que tu vas te
créer des espaces sur le tir mais il
faut en prendre une fixation quand même
tu peux mettre de l'argent sur un
intérieur oui après derrière iTunes
aujourd'hui tu regardes son rendement
c'est sûr par rapport aux attentes que
tu as sur un premier choix c'est
peut-être pas totalement si c'est pas
c'est pas totalement dingue c'est sûr
que c'est pas c'est pas aujourd'hui
franchise pierre que tu peux espérer
malgré tout le mec c'est c'est quand
même 17 18 points il doit être un peu
dire bon tu es en double double donc
c'est solide mais c'est
c'est par contre oui clairement au
dessus de au-dessus de sa du draft stock
réel du bonhomme je pense par rapport à
ce qu'il peut faire mais ça reste un
joueur
un vrai bon défenseur moi à l'époque
j'ai acheté plutôt son attaque que ça
défense et on a vu dans playoff que en
vrai aujourd'hui c'est peut-être un des
meilleurs intérieurs jeunes défenseur de
NBA
alors pour finir sur les scènes je vous
fais un petit Kikadi qui s'affiche
puisque on a une phrase d'une belle
lucidité
[Rires]
oui c'est reconnu c'est beau
mais je peux est-ce que je peux rajouter
un point sur des Android
moi je trouve que c'est lorsque les
équipes vont avoir le choix de racheter
un gars de ses pieds au début de la
drache ils vont toujours choisir le gars
de ses pieds puis je trouve que diandre
pour le montrer qui peut être le
troisième meilleur joueur d'une équipe
dans les finales de la NBA
et rester sur le plancher quand c'est
important donc on personne pouvait
s'attendre à ce que Lucas devienne extra
nucléaire de même j'ai l'impression que
diandre dans le contexte qu'il est c'est
un des contextes c'est une des c'est une
heure des aboutissements les plus
positifs qu'on peut ne pas avoir
offensivement parlant je crois que c'est
un chiffre serait beaucoup plus élevé
s'il avait pas un Chris Paul et devine
booker qui prennent énormément de
le problème c'est que le niveau de drap
de Don chic et son évolution donne une
perspective un petit peu biaisée au
reste 100%
place que tu ne gardes que le top 10
sans lui ça c'est plus ou moins cohérent
tu dis c'est une draft intéressante pas
forcément la plus folle mais c'est
plutôt solide et il y a des mecs qui
sont qui sont dans ce qu'on attend
et que vous aussi tu en trois
tu tu fausses en fait le l'évaluation de
par sa présence là mais est-ce qu'on
pourrait passer attendre quand même
romain est-ce qu'on pouvait pas s'y
attendre parce que le gars est MVP donc
18 ans quoi
je me rappelle de lui je me rappelle de
lui pour leur avion en live sur un euro
soit c'était l'Euro U20 à Bilbao en 2011
quelque chose comme ça
miroitide sur le Revin il marche sur les
os il domine tout le monde avec
l'Espagne on ne religue il est pas aussi
dominant que il est pas aussi mais en
Neuroligue il est quand même c'est un
joueur d'impact en Liga CB c'est un
joueur d'impact
la carrière
différents tout ce que vous voulez mais
la carrière qui avait des vrais
garanties de par son passage pro assez
tôt et son développement pro assez tôt
elle a pas été loin donc je pense que ça
peut être aussi
soulever des questions sur le sur
la projection possible on est tous
d'accord pour dire que quand il est en
Neuroligue à 18 ans et qui domine le
choc 2000 et le rôle Ligue des Champions
espagnol
oui c'est énorme
après derrière
c'est encore une fois si ton bailleur
cadala est-ce que ça se fait de la même
façon
toujours ces choses là sur Eli au Kobo
du coup tu pensais à l'époque c'était un
bon contexte non mais on le pensait
aussi je sens moi je pense que je pense
que c'est un bon contexte parce que
l'équipe est en construction parce que
le scoot de Phoenix à l'époque il est
français donc tu penses malgré tout que
si la franchise fait le choix de faire
venir allier au Kobo c'est parce que les
Intel sont suffisamment intéressantes
pour pour eux et puis que ça peut citer
moi j'ai croisé Elie en équipe de France
à l'époque je trouvais que c'était un
joueur intéressant et son évolution je
la trouve vraiment positive j'ai fait
une campagne avec lui son évolution je
trouve vraiment positive et ça me
paraissait pas déconnant de le voir
sortir sur du sur du deuxième tour le
contexte était bon après derrière ce qui
s'est passé une fois une fois là-bas
c'est encore une fois c'est un autre
débat mais le contexte n'était pas plus
mauvais pour lui pour pour d'autres
joueurs internationaux qui ont été
draftés au deuxième tour et dont
certains ont disparu ne joue plus on ne
religions aujourd'hui malgré tout ça
reste un joueur important de relig
ça a pas fonctionné sur le sur un sur un
sur un haut deuxième tour mais
aujourd'hui c'est un joueur c'est un
joueur de haut niveau qui est encore
avec l'utilité et qui encore l'activité
a très bon niveau donc c'est vrai je non
je modère pas mes propos je pense
toujours
attention un nouveau thème
assez flamboyant quand même j'avais
oublié qu'ils avaient très des Gary
traîne les Kings j'ai regardé c'est
extraordinaire et
on accueille
avec les lunettes
avec les lunettes de Jean Reno
désolé de de jump on the board ça me
fait plaisir de vous voir mais t'as quoi
et le problème c'est que si je fais ça
pour moi c'est Bruce Willis donc du coup
alors
mon Nico t'arrive au meilleur moment
parce que là on va quand même se
demander
dans l'histoire de la draft et ce qu'il
y a des décisions pires que de prendre
Marvin baglet à la place de Luka dans
chic ou parce que c'est ça la question
on sait que c'est une mauvaise décision
mais
ça me borit samouïe je suis désolé je
pense que c'est encore au dessus mais
c'est un peu plus vieux mais
il fait une carrière quand même
tu compares la carrière de somebody avec
la carrière du mec qui aurait pu être à
sa place il peut quand même te donner
d'accord je suis avec un marteau la
rumeur je voulais que sambaoui avait une
jambe plus longue que l'autre
c'est pour ça que j'ai pas fait carré
à part ça me BO oui tu vois qui Nico en
comparaison historique
qui Curie qui est passé devant par
Johnny Hallyday
j'aime bien croire que c'est de la faute
de challenge c'est une série de playoffs
entre les pistons c'est des net froid
Darko ils s'entraîne à Brooklyn avec son
son agent et il dit il setup c'est lui
qui raconte cette up tout un workout
j'ai dû marcher les pistons si j'arrive
il doit s'entraîner et c'est lui qu'on
veut
incroyable histoire
déjà le fait de mettre de la tutu
recontextualise sur l'époque série de
playoff avec New Jersey D3 tu dis que
c'est déjà assez déjà assez loin déjà
Nico tu as raté le moment où on disait
sur qui on s'était trompé dans cette
draft on a on a cité les noms de Shaggy
Jousse Alexander de MO Bamba
on a cité qui d'autre
est-ce que tu as un autre une autre
déception ah bah moi le mien il va il va
toucher notre ami canadien moi c'est
Kevin Gnass Kevin Knox pardon
moi c'était c'était limite au bout de
cinq ans c'était All Star et compagnie
donc bien bien bien gouré bien comme il
faut et quelle leçon tu as tiré de ça
alors il y en a une
est-ce qu'on a le droit de citer Laurent
Sierra
des dauphins t'en fais pas des requins
kidnox que j'ai sous-estimé je pense
c'est
peut-être la force mentale et aussi le
l'envie de tout casser ou pas mais là
dans ce cas là je crois que c'est le ou
pas
la ville y est pour beaucoup aussi on va
pas se mentir
ah bah ça
pas beaucoup de prospects qui
réussissent à New York quand même
je m'excuse mais à la draft 2018 on a eu
le prospect à New York qui est brisé la
mélodiction de Charlie World le premier
prospère savoir un deuxième contrat de
Nicks en presque 20 ans Michel Robinson
oui monsieur
alors ça c'est intéressant attendez je
vais vous mettre un je vais vous mettre
un Kikadi mais d'abord
Nico a le droit de nous dire quelle
couille il avait bien senti sur cette
draft c'est le moment où on s'auto qu'on
gratuit
quelle coup tu avais bien senti et
pourquoi tu penses que tu l'avais bien
senti
[Musique]
alors le truc facile c'était ton cheat
je pense que tous les Européens tous les
scouts européens
[Musique]
je dis ça compte pas
l'autre à un degré moindre c'est Wendel
Carter
le
ce qui on a plus de dire de lui à
Chicago je trouvais ça très
pas méchant mais c'était
exagéré par rapport à peut-être que les
attentes n'étaient pas les bonnes mais
en tout cas c'est un joueur qui a du
talent et qui est aujourd'hui capable
d'être starter 20 minutes je le voyais
comme ça je le voyais pas au-delà et
on dit j'ai raison c'est peut-être un
peu haut mais en tout cas si tu m'avais
passé un papier un stylo et que tu
m'avais demandé de dessiner un peu le
rôle qui pourrait avoir il y a
aujourd'hui avec les clés Magix je pense
que j'étais vraiment vraiment pas loin
tu étais dans le vrai
Manut avec qui en vrai
ça peut être un vrai qui s'est planté
d'ailleurs
pour moi c'était Michael Brigitte où
j'étais ultra fan de mémoire et il a
répondu à mes attentes même beaucoup
plus que ça parce que je pensais pas
qu'il allait devenir aussi bon au tir en
fait et c'est ce qui lui manquait pour
devenir un joueur NBA plus plus avec la
défense et aujourd'hui il a une défense
élite comme disait tout à l'heure il
aujourd'hui il est capable de défendre
sur le meilleur joueur
et il peut tirer à trois points voilà
c'est un vrai joueur de basket vrai rôle
player comme compris son rôle dès le
début il est tombé dans un contexte
moyen au début puis finalement le
travail de Phoenix au fil des années de
l'aider avec le développement de bunker
l'arrivée de l'arrivée de Chris Paul
assurance suite voilà tout est allé
parfaitement pour lui en fait et
on disait à l'époque le soir de la draft
c'est un joueur qui va c'est Antoine qui
disait ça à l'époque c'est un joueur qui
va avoir plus ou moins le même rôle en
NBA qu'il a eu à Vilanova
c'est plus ou moins ce qui s'est passé
même si développe des qualités
évidentes évidemment que tu continues de
progresser même si tu as 22 ans
développe
les qualités de qu'est-ce que tu fais si
le gars il se passe sur ta fin de fin
voilà le qualité de coupe qu'on ne
connaissait pas forcément de manière
évidente ou des qualités de pouvoir
poser un ou deux dribbles ou créer
des choses comme ça
ben qui
qui est à réussite j'avais j'étais très
très haut sur Michael bridges aussi je
le voulais à New York pour moi vous
connaissez un peu vous connaissez mon
style si tu sais jouer au basket c'était
capable de prendre un rôle dans une
équipe qui peut être capable de changer
de rôle dans une équipe le tir de
Michael budget j'ai acheté la défense de
Michael bridges j'ai acheté mais comme
Manu je crois qu'il est passé
complètement à un autre niveau je
croyais pas que physiquement il y allait
capable de prendre les impacts de la
manière dont il est prend en NBA donc
j'ai acheté mais je pense qu'il dépassé
la valeur dépasser mon prix d'achat
sinon je regardais plus loin il y a deux
joueurs qui ont été qui ont été
sélectionnés au deuxième tour que moi je
leur j'aimais beaucoup qui connaissent
une belle carrière il y a blues Brown
qui était à qui est à Denver maintenant
que bourgeonner
brooklynque très étrange carrière très
très étrange carrière mais ça fonctionne
moi je l'avais je pense l'auto quelque
chose du genre avant
la moitié de la saison
je crois qu'il jouait
dans une blessure au pied et l'autre
c'est
suspendu je crois pendant une
demi-saison moi j'ai acheté la défensive
hyper hyper rapide hyper exposé voilà
Spider-Man et c'est avec ça qui fait son
son pain son pain son beurre à NBA
présentement je l'avais au premier tour
au diatonie Melton je l'avais 25 sur le
meuble oui oui je me rappelle qu'on
était assez consensuellement plus haut
que que le 46
un truc
romain est-ce que tu as une souvenir
d'une belle réussite de l'évé bien
globalement qui est dans le dans le
stand et dans les attentes qu'on avait
par rapport à lui
je rejoins je rejoins ben par rapport à
Michael bridgi parce que Ben Vilanova
confirme son comment dire son son statut
de de fabrique à roleplayer de haut
niveau quand on sort de Vienne au vent
en général on sait ce qu'on a et puis je
mets un petit mention pour le trami
Kevin Werther qui
s'affirme dans la
c'est vrai je me rappelle t'avais
regardé les Scream Edge
[Musique]
au campagne tu nous avais dit les gars
Kevin Walter c'est on achète c'est 100%
vrai je mange je me rappelle ça c'est
vraiment
je l'avais vu un petit peu avant je suis
totalement par hasard sur un match de
Maryland et les maillots étaient me
rappeler ceux de Saint-Vallier en Pro B
c'est un petit peu attirer le regard
cette espèce de maillot absolument
horrible jaune rouge et
en fait j'ai tombé sur ce joueur là que
je trouve bien et qui aujourd'hui
s'impose à sarahmento comme une pièces
importantes donc pour un joueur drafté
19e un spécialiste en plus de rareté de
rareté 19 il y a une belle carrière
c'est je trouve une belle réussite par
rapport au rang quel est draft
je suis d'accord avec Hugues dans le
chat moi jarret Jackson Jr je voyais
encore plus fort que que ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui ce qui veut pas dire que qui
va pas le devenir parce qu'il y a eu des
gros problèmes
mais oui il est très bon et et si même
fils est candidat on verra ce que ce que
réserve le futur mais ce sera avec lui
qui joue poste 5 et à l'époque il est
quand il est drafté il s'est mentoré par
margazole au début de sa carrière ce qui
ce qui est pas si mal en terme de
professorat
Alan t'aimait bien Kevin Werther elle
était bien cette équipe de Maryland moi
j'étais fan de c'était
bien j'aime pas les intérieurs hauts
dans la draft mais si tu me les trouves
plus bas je les aime bien et les deux
que j'aimais bien c'était j'arrête van
derbilt moi j'étais j'adorais j'arrête
de vendre franchement je trouvais super
intéressant j'avais fait un petit un
petit une petite émission je trouvais
cinq styles d'une seconde tour et le
premier que je disais c'était j'arrête
van derbilt parce qu'en fait il pouvait
pas assez c'était un super rebondeur il
pouvait un peu switcher mais juste il
était blessé dans sa saison avec kentuy
je me souviens et en fait c'était pas le
bon contexte quand il y avait plus du
Washington il y avait Nick Richards
enfin c'était pas pour lui et l'année
dernière il est starter d'une équipe de
playoff avec Minnesota et cette année je
me mets avec Utah il est super beau
quand il doit jouer rentable il est à 8
points et demi en sortie de banc huit
points et demi quasiment deux bons
affami par match c'est pas en rotation
c'est pas mal autre exemple d'un gars
qui s'est juste joué au basket et
l'autre c'est il est dans la moyenne
athlétiquement mais
puis baskets
et l'autre c'est c'est rebrouillard
parce que l'année dernière c'est pour
moi c'est limite il doit être défenseur
de l'année en fait
qu'il a sur la défense des Celtics sur
la deuxième partie de saison quand il
dit il a ce rôle de toutes les
Américains un peu de sa rumeur
maintenant c'est à dire que c'est un il
est un peu loin du ballon mais il est
deuxième lame
l'an dernier et il change totalement la
défense de Boston il participe au fait
qu'ils vont finir NBA et en fait il
était je m'appelle il était à Texas CLN
et en fait il jouait post-4
dans une équipe où il y avait aussi un
peu de sang qui pouvait pas tirer qui
s'appelait Tyler Davis je sais pas si
vous souvenez qui était gaucher
c'était le pire spacing que j'avais
rarement vu c'était vraiment horrible en
fait c'était horrible et en fait
il était revenu sa saison sous forme de
mort alors que tout le monde disait que
s'il partait enfin sa saison freshman il
aurait pu être limite top 15 de la en
2017 il revient
et il parfum fin de premier tour et moi
je dis que c'était là où ça devait se
rater en fait rime Runner qui pourrait
avoir un vrai impact défensif et en fait
c'est plus que ça bien sûr mais c'est
une belle réussite pour pour lui et pour
l'esthétique mais cette équipe de Texas
franchement elle était horrible il
jouait vraiment avec deux postes 5 qui
pouvaient pas tirer même à 12h00
nous on l'aimait pas trop quand tu
réécoutes l'émission
Williams on les met pas trop à l'époque
parce que je crois qu'il rate la
conférence de
te dire il oublie ses papiers c'est pour
ça qu'on l'appelle Time Lord en fait moi
non c'est son surnom en fait c'est
mais c'est là où c'est là où peut-être
faudra fait ce genre de profil tu vois
tu prends le risque
dans la draft d'après ou deux ans après
si celle d'après il y a Nick klaxon et
un peu le même genre
[Musique]
mais beaucoup plus bas deuxième tour
oui c'est par là qu'il y a des il y a
des bonnes il y a des bonnes affaires
alors attention
encore un bel éclair de lucidité à
l'époque
qui qui a dit
ils ont drafté un gars il s'appelle
enfermis Simons on ne sait pas encore si
c'est un joueur
faut remettre dans le contexte il sort
de High School
et c'est moi c'est moi qui dit ça
[Musique]
c'est moi qui ai dit ça
et tout ça pour dire qu'à l'époque
on oublie totalement et
on faisait pas chez envergure on gardait
pas les mecs au lycée mais Michel
Robinson comment faire Nice Simons on ne
savait pas qui c'était et on passe à
côté et aujourd'hui en faire un Symons
c'est un peu l'exemple
du développement enfin du de la prédraft
ce que tu appelles la prédraft
avant en fin de premier tour ou deuxième
partie comme ça parce que si jamais il
revient à la fac où il va à la fac il
sera pris top 5 tout top 10 ce qui est
benoitu en fait ce que les gens
voulaient faire avec Benoit en 2021 il
avait dit mets ton nom on prendra fin de
premier tour parce que j'avais peur
qu'en fait que si il revenait il serait
rater beaucoup plus haut je pense que
Simone c'est le meilleur exemple de
pour nous tous peut-être regarder autre
chose que voilà l'année nier regarder
d'autres choses essayer de projeter
différemment et que mais ça reste super
compliqué parce que tu auras fait un
jour que sur ce qui fait à IMG Academy
ça reste dur mais je pense c'est un
joueur avocat c'est un peu comme je te
donne Shark en dernier
donc oui et corrigez-moi si je me trompe
mais il y avait pas joué je crois
l'année de la draft
de 21h06
on ne te le souhaite dans les autres
anecdotes
inutiles Alex c'est toi qui m'envoie un
texto pendant le
train cap pour me demander si en
finissime ça a vraiment grandi oui en
fait entre ça draft et aujourd'hui il a
pris 3 inchies je crois donc c'est la
preuve qu'il est il était pas fini il
était loin d'être fini même
vraiment pris leur temps avec il y avait
sidgé mes colum qui jouait devant lui
lui ont laissé tout le temps de se
développer lui ont donné beaucoup
d'amour puis c'est ce qu'on voit quand
on donne de l'amour et qu'on est une
équipe une franchise
qui a des bonnes valeurs ça fait ça fait
fleurir des joueurs
absolument on va demander à Manu de
réagir sur le prochain qui a dit c'est
pas lui qui a prononcé la phrase mais
c'est pas mal non plus ça donne
du lendemain de la draft donc c'est moi
qui informe l'auditeur en disant mot
Wagner c'est l'homme qui a les plus
grandes mains au combat et quelqu'un
répond si tu veux faire Arthur artiste
de cirque c'est pas mal romain bien sûr
et donc on avait je sais pas ce qu'on
avait contre Nova gnor mais alors on
l'avait défoncé pendant 10 minutes move
Wagner c'était mis à plusieurs des
visionnaires et movagner il a pas fait
une grande carrière et alors la draft
des Lakers quand même cette année-là
c'est pas mal du tout puisqu'il draft
Isaac Bonga move
de mémoire non
j'ai pas de gros souvenir de lui en fait
à michilian beaucoup plus de son final
il y avait donc dans cette équipe
de Cannes Robinson vous avez retenu le
son sur dunken Robinson
personne l'avait vu venir celle-ci
après c'est l'évolution du jeu quoi on a
tous un ami qui est capable d'aller au
marché aux puces puis trouver des
trésors
[Rires]
ah oui c'est une belle c'est une belle
image belle image
ah on a on n'a pas parlé de lui ça me
permet de mettre un petit Kikadi de
nouveau
pour mon Wagner Alex c'est sûr que si
s'il y en a qui ont regardé le Shiba
Europe je sais plus c'est U16 ou 18 en
2014 avec mon Wagner c'est c'est soft
soft soft donc c'est normal après que
qu'on se dise ça va pas marcher parce
que un peu comme son frère c'est des
joueurs quand on les avions compétition
de jeunes et ensuite en NBA tu dis c'est
pas c'est son cousin c'est son où il a
chopé la rage entre temps mais c'est pas
les mêmes joueurs
après mon Wagner aujourd'hui il est
backup du backup Orlando
de la sélection de move Wagner selon
Mitch Robinson Robinson a eu une
promesse de Lakers à 25% qui s'était
retiré du processus près de Raph et mon
Wagner aurait absolument conquis
Magic Johnson la mort comme quoi les les
dirigeants NBA peuvent se faire avoir
comme des enfants de cœur
il est là pour faire plaisir à son frère
je pense qu'ils défonce pas mal Orlando
présentement
par match pour prendre qu'on avait bien
sous-estimé peut-être à cause de mots
une nouvelle phrase qui est qui est pas
mal
qui concerne Coline Sexton
si LeBron Park Sexton a les clés du
camion bon ce sera un camion de glace
mais quand même
j'ai envie de dire Antoine
exactement
Antoine Béranger qui nous manque qui
aurait dû être là si son opérateur avait
fait du bon travail Coline Sexton
comment vous l'évaluiez à l'époque
est-ce qu'il a eu la carrière que vous
attendiez
je le trouvais un peu un peu ligne
droite un peu genre
j'essaie de défoncer tout le monde je
rentre à la droite le tir était un peu
difficile aussi c'était pas mauvais mais
c'était très rigide comme mécanique de
tir c'est très c'est très mécanique en
fait
il y a eu une meilleure carrière jusqu'à
date que à quoi je m'étais attendu papa
pas beaucoup mais
respectable présentement
oui oui il sort du banc il est
titulairement je
regarde tout de suite
Manu toi tu l'aimais pas ça c'est
vraiment un joueur qui est pas Manu ça
c'est pas un joueur Manu
j'étais pas ouais
je sais pas la Bama j'ai des bons
souvenirs
[Musique]
que
qu'on ne l'aurait pensé et surtout il
sera encore à Cleveland si Darius
Garland
n'était pas Darius Garland
oui en fait
[Musique]
et peut-être une meilleure aussi
progression s'il avait pas croisé
Garland
finalement garde après sa place quoi
j'ai un nom
sur la même draft finalement et
l'empathie
j'ai un nom à vous soumettre et
j'aimerais que vous me disiez qu'est-il
devenu
le choix numéro 13 de cette draft
Jérôme
à Washington Washington
et là je pense qu'il est
j'ai pas la réponse j'ai pas fait mes
devoirs
oui joue pour les Warriors
et en concurrence avec 10 Santos
et immédiatement
il est au Brésil mon guide
à l'époque le soir de la draft en fait
j'ai un gros doute parce qu'on était
tous en train de dire Jérôme Robinson en
13 c'est n'importe quoi mais à ce moment
là les Clippers sortent quand même de
plusieurs années où ils doivent pas trop
mal
et d'ailleurs ils prennent Gilles juice
Alexander donc c'est la preuve que tu
peux être à la fois bon et pas bon sur
la même draft
et surtout c'est Jerry West en fait qui
fait la décision et visiblement c'est
lui qui dit Jérôme Robinson c'est mon
gars quoi alors est-ce que
pourquoi il était issurévalué comme ça
qu'est-ce qu'on peut retenir de cette de
cette leçon
Jérôme Robinson qu'est-ce que vous en
dites
si je me rappelle bien à l'époque
j'avais dit quelque chose genre ils ont
dû doivent savoir quelque chose qu'on
sait pas
sur lui et bien donc olafa faut lui
faire confiance je vais pas beaucoup vu
Jérôme Robinson mais ça m'avait l'air
d'une d'une hype de fin de saison
pour moi c'est un bon joueur de College
mais je voyais pas
le talent plus la capacité oui il était
grand je me rappelle il était il est
plutôt grand pour ça sa position mais je
voyais pas un premier pas incroyable ta
création pour les autres du playmaking
c'est un bon shooter il faudra faire
pour le shoot mais si tu dors pour le
shoot il y a un mec qui prie juste
derrière désolé mais tu prends le risque
on en a pas encore parlé mais
je dois prendre un risque voilà si tu
prends ils ont deux pics tu dois prendre
un risque tu te prends pas sur Jérôme tu
le prends sur Michael
Michael Porter junior effectivement qui
est drafté en 14 à l'époque on est assez
d'accord pour dire que c'est une bonne
situation pour lui
parce que c'est pas une équipe très
exposée quoi
que le porteur junior pour rappeler son
parcours NCIS
3 matchs et une blessure au dos et enfin
non une blessure au dos il revient pour
trois matchs il est catastrophique il
arrive pas à courir et il est drafté 14
avec le bon il est toujours pas très
solide physiquement mais il est encore
blessé
mais suivre tout le temps mais c'est
quand même sans blessure c'est l'un des
meilleurs joueurs
il était classé premier au deuxième
ouais c'est ça oui oui avant avant
l'année
il était classé devant dans le shitch
j'ai la chance nuggets il y a deux mois
je l'ai vu c'est chauffer pendant 30
minutes c'est irréel
sans toucher c'est irréel
c'est quand il veut où il veut il est il
fait 6 10 un sac les gens se rendent pas
il est grand et avec un distributeur
Insider comme yukic c'est juste que ça
ça met son meilleur jour en valeur à mon
avis
aucun problème avant il devait aller à
Washington et finalement il va m'y
sourire parce que il suit le coach et
parce que Missouri prend le frère
voilà le papa aussi il y avait plein de
bruit avant la draft sur la famille le
physique et tout c'était il faut dire
que ça moins bien réussi avec son frère
il y a le troisième frère
c'est mon standing
ils ont un potentiel de triple
je vous mets un petit dialogue
puisque
je vais lire pour ceux qui font écouter
mais à l'époque donc c'est un dialogue à
trois et on est les trois sur la ligne
du haut là donc romain dit j'ai très
peur de Charlotte c'est un espèce de
marécage permanent j'ai coupé le moment
où tu dis que c'est construit sur du
sable mais d'ailleurs vous noterez que
le terme de marécage je l'ai utilisé
pour Orlando il y a quatre cinq minutes
c'est vrai
et donc ben renchérit ils sont sur le
tapis roulant de la médiocrité et je
conclus en parlant de Miles bridges qui
est de rester à l'époque par
les honnêtes
peut-on je demande au prof Nico peut-on
anticiper ce qui est devenu miles
j'ai pas les Intel de l'époque c'est sûr
que si
ça nous est arrivé il y a très peu de
temps il y a eu des
un joueur européen qui avait minjif là
sont à son professeur en classe bon si
tu as ça en Intel que tu draves quand
même et puis au final tu te rends compte
que le gars s'inscrit au championnats du
monde de gifle les gifle toutes les
personnes qui sont proches autour de lui
tu te dis bon ben c'est pour moi je le
savais je l'ai pris
[Musique]
maintenant quand tu t'intéresses à des
Intel sur des jeunes qui ont 17 18 ans
à part si on te dit il aime beaucoup la
bouteille etc c'est super difficile de
pouvoir prévoir que que le type puisse
finir en prison pour faire ce qu'il a
fait donc là dessus oui et non si
vraiment tu as des Intel pourries ok son
père est en prison pour avoir tué sa
mère et lui il mange il mange des pneus
de voiture le matin bon voilà tu dis ok
là c'est sûr que ça peut il va falloir
lui mettre quelqu'un à côté de lui là
dans cette histoire la maman elle
travaille au sens où aussi que ça
Michael est normale ils sont pas frais
attends là je découvre
[Rires]
dans ma tête ça fait 4 ans ils sont ils
sont ils sont frère incroyables avec des
prénoms comme ça tu sais le nom
[Musique]
c'est toi voilà c'est gros mythe donc du
coup ok voilà ça fait ça fait une belle
une belle punchline contre moi c'est
beau donc ok donc voilà ça dépend encore
une fois c'est une réponse de Normand
mais oui
je m'attendais pas à ce que tu me dises
oui ou non
la boule de cristal c'est
c'est réservé à Magic Johnson pour faux
bridges
si on avait pu anticiper effectivement
pas mis aussi mais nous à l'époque pour
revenir sur le
moment où il est drafté on pense que
c'est pas si mal qu'il soit drafté à
Charlotte c'est un bon site
c'est un bon film parce qu'on se dit
peut jouer 4
on peut jouer 4 il est athlétique ils
ont pas l'habitude Charlotte d'abord des
quatre athlétiques ils sortent de Tyler
Hans Brown ah non il était
au basket non il fait des podcasts sur
la
Ntwin
si nous écoutent on le salut
est-ce que vous avez
est-ce que qu'est-ce que je vous avais
demandé d'autres j'avais d'autres
questions
que j'avais mis dans les dans les
sondages alors attention parce que
j'avais la meilleure draft effectivement
les maps on était d'accord qui a fait la
PIRE draft
c'est on peut dire bravo à Mathieu qui
m'informe que Jeff Bridges n'est pas le
père non plus
le père
pour de la provoc
je m'excuse mais les Kings
malheureusement pas loin mais les Kings
ça restera je pense que dans 10 ans
c'est un mot
on parle encore donc
j'étais pas encore connecté vous avez
vous avez expliqué la raison non
ok d'accord je vois romain qui me
regarde
officieusement j'ai pas parlé avec Lady
vache en personne mais officieusement
c'est c'est les la mésentente
de longue date entre le papa d'entic et
vladimat qui qui donne envie à vlader de
voir ailleurs
c'est la version n'est pas dans les
livres ça c'est la version qui est pas
vrai pas dans le pas dans le pas dans
solide et
juste avant la draft divach ou juste
après divajdi qui veut faire jouer
Marvin baglet poste 3
ça fait malheureusement oublier ce
magnifique
le bord qui avait liké aussi genre
plusieurs mois après
une photo il y avait un top 5 ou quelque
chose comme ça genre donc si tu étais 4
le premier c'était étonne après ça
devait être un bagulée
le classement avait aucun sens
quand vous avez signé un thème des
contrat il y avait la photo tu avais le
porte sur le qu'est-ce que tu fais le
top 5 est incroyable
j'aime tous les shooters
les détails du trade c'est deux futurs
deuxième choix et de la
honte bah après que si c'est juste
contre parce que Gary Trent il est 30 et
quelques
si ça devient pas gigari traite et si ça
devient je te donne un random nom de
cette draft-là type
Arnold Arnold das culbocca par exemple
du coup tu le regrettes pas trop quoi
de là pour aller chercher Gary Trump
Nico je t'entends pas je vois que tu
bouges les lèvres mais je t'entends pas
pardon c'est mieux avec pour revenir sur
le drive board des Kings qui avait
liquide ils avaient en 1 etton en deux
baglets en trois dentiste en quatre
porteurs en 5 bambins et en 6 bridges
mais il y a pas marqué à côté si c'est
Mickaël
[Rires]
Kairi ah oui bien joué directement
on a dû le jouer il était de roster de
toface Boursin on a joué on a dû le
jouer en BCL en début d'année je crois
qu'il n'a pas mis les pieds sur le
terrain qui les rentré aux États-Unis
quelque chose comme ça
jamais bien le profil
alors j'aimerais bien on va faire un
petit est-ce que vous est-ce qu'il y a
des sujets dont on n'a pas parlé que
vous vouliez évoquer puisque là je crois
qu'on a presque la réforme des retraites
oui on
recevra Olivier du subvre dans la
deuxième partie de ce podcast je
jetterais donc des objets sur mon écran
c'est parfait
non
bah oui je sais mais ta cité
Saint-Vallier on a cité Saint-Vallier et
Olivier du socle tu vois
on reste dans le local
les meubles d'Alan qui a changé de
mobilier oui il pouvait pas les emmener
tu les as pas emmenés Alan tu es
commodes
si tu payes au kilo c'est ça coûte hyper
cher quoi
du coup de la vie je sais pas je t'en
parle pas
non je suis dans le bureau là je suis au
bureau une bonne connexion
dans le chat si vous avez des
questions n'hésitez pas primo il en est
où bon ça ça nous intéresse pas
on sait pas il est où mais on sait qu'il
est nul
[Rires]
pas nu short avec rien en dessous un
short
échancré
non ce que je mettais dans le chat c'est
pour moi le fit est bon dans le sens où
tu peux pas dire qu'il a pas eu sa
chance
après le shoot c'est pas forcément
amélioré et puis il est régulier au
possible et là avec les Lakers aussi vu
l'effectif il a il a ses minutes il a sa
chance et c'est
ça ressemble j'espère me tromper parce
que c'est un joueur que j'adore j'étais
tombé amoureux de lui pendant la seconde
ligue parce que vraiment il était il
était au-dessus du lot il était il était
facile mais ça ressemble à un joueur qui
pourrait
finir journée même à être tradé à chaque
trade line tous les ans ou finir par
arriver au panne Inti naikos ou Avallon
d'ici peu quoi
intéressant parce que c'est vraiment un
code de joie qu'un profil que j'aime pas
puis qui tourne exactement comme je
l'anticipe parce que c'est le premier
profil que j'aime pas c'est un joueur
que on sait pas qu'est-ce qui va on sait
pas qu'est-ce qu'il a de particulier
[Musique]
alors une question et si Mathieu bonne
question zanane Moussa qui est drafté à
l'époque par les net donc de Brooklyn
on va encore parler de d'extra sportif
je crois
que le podcast bilan de la draft
juste après mon Wagner celui qu'on prend
le plus dans la gueule c'est Moussa
parce que il y avait des Intel qui était
très mauvais et
pardon caractère de cochon voilà
Antoine Antoine dit je l'ai pas noté
celle-là c'est dommage mais de mémoire
il dit Zana moussaï c'est faire que deux
choses prendre des tirs et faire chier
ses coéquipiers
donc c'était plutôt fin je sais pas si
Nico t'étais intéressé par
je me suis gouré aussi de très bonne
leçon de la Moussa parce que
toi je je
voyais là où les autres voyaient un
caractère trop affirmé quelqu'un qui va
être dur à contrôler moi je voyais ça
comme une force en me disant il a le
caractère pour y arriver et là encore
quoi bonne leçon sur et d'ailleurs pour
les je pense pour le système Balkan
c'est à dire que de mettre un joueur au
centre et de faire en sorte que tout le
monde mette par terre pour pas que ses
pieds touche le sol c'est très bien pour
sortir pro mais pour ensuite devenir
une star NBA ou en tout cas s'imposer en
NBA ne me dites pas dans le site
puisqu'il a joué en Espagne il a été
formé en Espagne mais
[Musique]
il manque pas grand chose mais peut-être
il manquait le plus important au final
un autre joueur bien random dont on nous
parle dans le chat Kevin nous parle de
l'immense Chandler à chinson boys
est-ce que tu te rappelles de ce que tu
pensais de Chandler et
parce qu'il avait tout on avait tout de
suite appris qu'il avait une promesse
des boules
franchement assez peu assez peu
plus c'est Bronco j'aime que moi mon
broncourt à moi donc
mais non mais je sais pas
il sont quand même sortis depuis que
voilà c'est le coach toujours des bons
rôles Player et lui c'était peut-être la
meilleure version c'était un mémoire un
évier il savait un peu passé de RIB de
shooter il avait plus de 100 matchs NCIS
je pense qu'ils achetaient ils
achetaient
peut-être un poste de 3 qui pouvait
servir sur les ailes et tout ce qui peut
être qu'ils avaient acheté avec Denzel
Valentine de 3 ans avant d'ailleurs mais
ça a pas ça n'a pas fonctionné peut-être
qu'il y a la partie mentale aussi parce
que s'il a arrêté sa carrière si jeune
et tout ça je aucune idée mais non
j'aime pas trop de souvenirs
dans le trade de avec Troy brun junior
et Maurice Carter
[Musique]
ça va pas vraiment quoi faire avec non
plus
il est drôle player aujourd'hui
alors qu'il est drafté pour être un peu
plus
après hydrater par Washington
il y a des équipes on sait que c'est
plus compliqué ah oui je vous avais
demandé d'élire le talent gâché alors je
sais que Nico vote pour Lony Walker
j'avais proposé
il est au Kobo
Loni Walker troi brand junior Zaïre
Smith
et après vous avez le droit de citer
d'autres noms dites-moi qui est le talon
gâché par le contexte dans lequel il
arrive de cette draft
ce que j'ai droit de nommer
tu as le droit tout à fait le droit
mais il faut que tu marguments
[Musique]
de pas vraiment de de shooter je crois
qu'ils ont mis un peu ils l'ont essayé
un peu à toutes les sauces
sans jamais vraiment avoir de plan pour
lui puis il se retrouve ce qui est à ce
qu'une équipe présentement au juste je
ne crois pas je vois les sens
jamais été je crois qu'il y avait un
potentiel de rôle player plus fort que
ça qui sait jamais que jamais vraiment
été développé parce qu'on était dans une
franchise qu'il y avait aucune idée de
ce qu'elle faisait
mais il a jamais su trop shooter non
plus ce qui est un peu compliqué
je pense qu'on l'a jamais mis dans une
position pour apprendre à shooter sur le
terrain non plus parce qu'on l'a jamais
de donner trop de gilets légumes pour
faire des erreurs
accorder le droit de faire des erreurs
non plus j'avais beaucoup le potentiel à
l'époque puis il y a à peu près au même
point qu'on est en 2018
qui qui a d'autres propositions pour
pour notre on a beaucoup de Kevin Knox
dans la dans le chat
parce que je l'avais pas beaucoup
regardé moi j'écoutais surtout je lisais
surtout ce qu'on pouvait dire de lui et
tu as coupé le son Nico
pardon ouais je disais il est jamais
arrivé au final
il est jamais arrivé à destination mais
du coup qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
qu'est-ce qu'on fait tu vois à un moment
donné il y a une blessure et un machin
mais ce qui a si on dit talents gâcher
ça veut dire que c'est pas que un
problème de détection et que il y a un
vrai talent et qu'on l'a pas mis au bon
endroit donc comme
moi je voyais ça plus le différentiel
entre ce qu'on attendait de lui avant la
draft et ce que ça donne au final donc
tu disais Wendel Carter junior ouais
parce que pour moi je viens de chercher
parce que parce que c'est un super
joueur mais pour moi c'est il a le
potentiel pour être l'un des quatre
meilleurs joueurs de cet offre je pense
que je le vois je pense qu'en termes
d'aikyu de passing de défense
d'intelligence de jeu de
je pense que je Chicago ça a tué son
début de carrière comme ils ont tué le
début de guerre de Lorie marcanen parce
que pas avoir de vrai
qu'on pensait voir les deux Carter et
marcelaine les deux ont besoin de partir
de Chicago d'avoir des meneurs pour les
mettre dans des bonnes dispositions
d'avoir des une
ossature sérieuse pour se montrer en
fait Carter c'est pas que c'est pas que
tu le contexte a tué parce que Nicolas
dit on a tout simplement il a un plafond
un plancher très solide on sait ce qu'on
a avec model Carter c'est du 15 8 4
solides intelligent mais je pense
vraiment qu'il y avait un potentiel chez
lui de plus et je pense que il va le
montrer à Orlando mais pour l'instant je
trouve que Chicago a un peu il y en
avant et pas aider son début de carrière
et c'est positif ce que j'adore ce jour
vraiment
on attend avec impatience le trade de
Patrick Williams du coup
bah oui c'était pas crise donne le
meneur non chrisden parle la saison
d'avant
du côté de ah non il arrive si c'est ça
il arrive de lui donner
ils ont ils ont ils essaient du Kobe
en fait voilà non quoi pour développer
tes jeunes intérieurs faut pas ça on va
parler de Jeremy Jackson junior bah il a
eu mycon le sa première année avec
margason à côté et après il a
on voit la différence
c'est compliqué
effectivement Manu est-ce que tu as un
autre nom pour le talent gâché avec ta
langue gâché
pas trop je regarde la liste là il y a
rien qui me saute aux yeux
peut-être que
il avait tant de talent que ça
rendu un peu plus un supérieur
honnêtement encore meilleur vous tient
notamment mais autrement parmi la liste
par les 60
il y a rien qui me dit ah ouais lui en
fait je le voyais bien bien meilleur que
ça ou contexte
moi je pense Marvin baglet quand même
pardon je sais que
on les met pas trop parce que il était
vu trop mais ce qu'il est meilleur des
trois ça aurait dû être un meilleur ça
aurait dû être un joueur offensif bah
oui
ta productivité offensive quand même
même s'il pouvait pas défendre
franchement il aurait dû avoir quasiment
le même niveau que Hayton ou en tout cas
nager dans les dans des eaux similaires
s'il est mis au bon endroit avec des
mais Antoine d'ailleurs dit c'est un
jour au moment de sa draft il dit c'est
un joueur qui a besoin d'une culture
basket d'un vrai encadrement
bon bah voilà il est tombé à Sacramento
qui lui donne pas à ce moment-là c'est
encadrement
je vais vous donner je vais avoir là
d'un prophète d'apocalypse c'est à dire
ça mais je vais je vais être intégré
avec mes prédictions de l'époque il y a
un joueur que j'aimais beaucoup à
tulingue qui s'appelait
en fin de premier tour j'avais 28 ou 29e
était de rajouter 35e à Orlando il a été
absolument enterré dans le chaos
primordial d'Orlando et de Oklahoma City
il est présentement il est en train de
pourrir en 10 League présentement est-ce
que le train est passé pour Melvin
freezieux peut-être un ailier qui était
ultra long je pense qu'il y avait 7,2 de
de de winspand d'envergure il était il
était capable de shooter il y a pas été
capable de répliquer ça malheureusement
dans le peu de de répétition chaotique
il y a eu dans la ligue je pense qu'il a
joué genre 30 matchs en 4 ans et moi je
trouve que ça c'est un talent gâché je
trouve ça intéressant
et je ne crois pas malheureusement qui
va se développer en un joueur NBA
maintenant
un petit kick a dit sauf si vous avez
d'autres talents gâché
c'est non allez
celui-là c'était le meilleur
sonne comme du Nico mais je pense pas
que Nico était là à l'époque
amoureuse mais pour brouiller les pistes
j'ai dit j'ai t'avais dit en amour oh
oui clairement
alors c'est incroyable parce que quand
j'ai écouté ça je me suis dit c'était
vraiment fou à l'époque il y avait des
citations folles c'est trop cadré
aujourd'hui j'ai plus personne qui dit
ça me casse
ma mère était en amour avec Gilbert
Bécaud et on a parlé de Gilbert Bécaud
pendant deux trois minutes je vous
invite à aller réécouter le le live pose
draft c'était une digression ah oui il y
avait des vrais bons moments
allez on va je vais vous je vais vous je
vais finir avec un petit quiz alors là
je vais vous donner
les positions à laquelle ils sont drafté
il me faudra donner le nom
évidemment on va partir sur des secondes
tout
alors
un petit quiz qui
a été drafté
au par les pélicans
en 51
si tu dis les universités l'autre avec
son logiciel il va nous fumer
quelles chaussures il portait le soir de
la draft ok ok ok ok ok ok
alors attention
ah oui c'est bon ça
attends il faut que je il a jamais
trouve-nous ces infos il joue au bacon
vert
à Turin à cantou à Parme à terme pardon
en Russie c'est pas pareil
c'est bon ça alors là là on va on va
tomber sur le choix de Washington
au second tour
c'est un joueur
qui donc c'est drafté en 44 et plutôt en
arrière un mètre 93
la légende la légende INEX de New York
news
c'est pas marqué c'est marqué qui joue
en ligue letton aujourd'hui
[Musique]
ah ok d'accord
il souffre
parce que c'est cool non mais je pense
que j'ai vu ce j'ai vu soit là passé
plusieurs fois parce que à cause de
qualité
[Rires]
complètement fou alors là je vais vous
demander
évidemment il y a toujours un grand
pivot blanc drafté au second
un grand pivot blanc qui est drafté par
les Nuggets
et oui oh oui c'est vrai et oui oui
aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui je joue au
Japon
je me souviens de regarder à Marseille
en deuxième division japonaise donc il
est il a une sur une légère pente
descendante
là où là vont mourir
tu as dit quoi romain
et en 2021
ça recoupe romain ça recoupe ton son
mais oui effectivement Championnat du
Monde du 19 il gagne l'or
donc il fait partie de la sélection U19
des États-Unis j'avais complètement
oublié que ce qu'elle a existait
alors moi il y a un gars que je
non je vais vous mettre celui que je
connais quand même parce que il y en a
je sais même pas
je savais même pas qu'ils existaient
alors
aujourd'hui
et aujourd'hui c'est un joueur qui qui
évolue en Europe et qui
je crois qui s'en sort pas trop mal si
mes souvenirs sont bons
drafté par par
le Thunder 57
il joue au virus Bologne aujourd'hui
vous êtes juste des fois par contre vous
me permet de vous le faire
remarquerions tous nos prédictions
étaient absolument exactes
est-ce que je peux leur poser un quiz
sur quel est le seul joueur de la draft
2018 qui a joué avec Elie au Kobo à
l'ASVEL l'an dernier
c'est beau c'est beau je
vous en faire un petit dernier mais
j'essaie de trouver un bien dur quoi
bien compliqué alors attention
Christophe il y a quand même mis le son
de Romain c'est retour en 2018 aussi
[Rires]
c'est beau
alors attendez je cherche allez on va
partir mais Keven Hervé ça avait déjà
genre 36 ans à l'époque l'adresse
oui oui
tout à fait oh oui ça c'est bon ça
en 76
ça va plus du tout
donc c'est un joueur qui fait 2 mètres
08 6 pieds 10 pour tourner
qui
est le fils
quoi qu'est-ce que c'est que
Gilbert Bécaud
alors
c'est un joueur qui a pas mal vadrouillé
qui a commencé au Maverick même s'il est
sélectionné John Bronson non non
ensuite il va non non c'est un peu c'est
un grand c'est un power for Wars
ensuite il va au sens mais il joue peu
Rio Grande dévalley Vipers Charlotte Le
Grinch boroswarm les roquettes
et depuis il est donc au Rio Grande des
vallées Vipers il y a un nom de soulier
j'ai envie de dire nous balance mais je
me rappelle plus son nom je me rappelle
il a pas un nom de soulier il a un mec
je l'aimais ce soir là à Louisville
[Rires]
c'est beau voilà on finira sur race
palding
qui a donc pris le nom de sa mère si je
croise
parce que on est d'accord que Raymond
c'est quand même un prénom que d'hommes
ça n'existe pas les Raymond enfin
Raymond tout seul
[Musique]
[Rires]
la mère de Gilbert Bécaud
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis merci
au chat pour pour la participation
c'était beau
Nico Nico t'es aux États-Unis ou tu es
en France non non je rentre de voyage
vers l'instant là c'est pour ça que le
cerveau il est encore en décalage
horaire mais non je suis à la maison OK
et bien à bientôt par message mais je
pense ça fait plaisir aux
auditeurs et viewers du coup de votre
retour à toi et et Alan Guillou qui va
entamer les matchs de conférence
[Musique]
ok Santa Clara il y a un vlog on peut te
suivre tes aventures
non allez suivre la page Twitter
sur tinder Alex sur tinder il y a une
place pas du tout
c'est le Bronco de Santa Clara
[Rires]
[Musique]
pour les pour les podcasts on vous
renvoie sur notre dernier Podcast si
vous voulez sur sur Victor web banama
puisque vous ne savez pas tout
contrairement à ce que vous pouvez
penser et il y a un certain romain qui
témoigne avec bowdium Massa sur comment
stopper Victor ou comment essayer
donc c'est pas mal romain évidemment
tout le meilleur pour la SIG pour ce
mois de janvier continuer la remonter au
classement
et Manu tout le scouting du monde
tu vois jouer qui demain
Levallois
on se voit demain
salut tout le monde merci de nous avoir
suivi
pardon il y a des espoirs aussi ou pas
passer une journée à Levallois
allez un petit un petit shoot out à
Bilal Coulibaly et on ferme le stream